with transformative technology and at
the transformative technology lab we're
tracking ten major areas of Transtech
and those ten areas include things like
neurofeedback and biofeedback neuro stem
and bio stem those are the ones that I
think people would think of the most a
good example of that would be the amuse
headset by inter axon that measures your
EEG so measures your brainwaves
another thing that's coming out is neuro
stem a good example of that would be a
company called halo Neuroscience and so
it's a it's a it's a slight stimulation
to the brain that in their trials with
elite athletes they're showing people
having big surges in ability and so
that's kind of interesting there's
another product called think that sits
on the forehead right here and it
stimulates the peripheral nerves and
sort of could replace a cup of coffee so
it sort of stimulates you and wakes you
up so there's a lot of focus on things
that are taking feedback from the body
and then stimulating the body and so it
could be the body or the brain one of
the things that is coming is a lot of
vagus nerve stimulation and the on the
medical side there's research that's
recently come out where people are
really taking that more seriously in
addition some of the things that I think
are really cool is I'm really intrigued
by emotion recognition software whether
that through cameras that are watching
facial expressions I or through or
another example would be there's a
company called beyond verbal that just
off of the audio files can pick up human
emotion
and you might think well you know sort
of what's the use of that I know how I
feel but it's actually if you think
about it
when everything in your house is smart
you're really gonna want to want it to
know if you're upset said or not you
know if you're upset or not so you know
I have a friend older friend that I
bought a Amazon echo for and she
whispers around the echo like it's a
real person this is someone who's in
there who's in their 70s and so for
people who were growing up in smart
houses which you know a lot of children
today they they won't even know a time
where there isn't a certain level of
intelligence that's baked into their
environment we're gonna want all these
things to know how we feel I think that
emotion recognition is really
interesting it's the thing that's
captured my imagination right now
there's a lot of interest right now in
neuro stem and a lot of that is based on
a series of studies that were done by
DARPA where they were using slight
electrical stimulation and saw a
increase in task acquisition for people
in various roles in the military the one
that's the most well known is for the
increase or the acceleration for
sharpshooters from novice to expert with
the application of a slight electrical
stimulation while they were learning
there's a lot of people who are really
interested in that there's actually a
really large do-it-yourself community
around the world where people are doing
citizen independent science really and
do-it-yourself science and using various
levels of electrical currency on their
own brains and then sharing it in forums
and communicating about it people have
been trying electrical stimulation with
physical task acquisition also language
tasks acquisition it's one of those
things that there's products that are
being based on it there's a whole
category of things with called
transcranial direct stimulation
and so there's a lot of products out
there on that some of the brand names
that you might find would be focus is
one halo neuroscience is another the
think product is another and so it's
starting to have commercial products for
it there also was a as you can imagine
there's a lot of the medical community
is a little concerned about it
it's a good example of where people
individuals are really sort of pushing
ahead of where the medical community is
on you know what's a good idea for what
levels of stimulation you should have
how often and and where you know what
part of the of the brain that you try to
stimulate through the surface and so
it's really it's a it's an interesting
space and people are pushing into it